we exist here at the stanford executive  program to help you change your life and  in the process change the organization  you lead in and change the world you  touch  that's why we exist  our curriculum it gives you content it  gives you ideas but more than that it  helps you understand the meaning of  leadership  leadership is much more  than knowledge  of functional activities or skills  leadership is an honor  and with honor comes duty  the duty to create your organization a  context that will help them thrive in  ways they never dreamed of come here to  stanford to fulfill that view of your  role as a leader  [Applause]  [Music]  you